- My friends, how do you
not understand that you have
to produce 100 pieces of content a day?
How do you not understand that
everyday that you wake up,
whether it for yourself,
or for your business,
or your ambition, or your organization,
how do you not understand
that you should be putting out
50 to 100 pieces of content a day?
(whooshing)
(popping)
YouTube, what's up?
So, so grateful that you
clicked and you're about
to watch a new YouTube
video, but before you do
212-931-5731
that is my texting community platform.
I'm doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there
and also access opportunity,
first looks in that environment
212-931-5731,
join it now and now to the video
you've been wanting to watch.
(sirens)
(men shouting)
You got your perspective.
(racing techno music)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
Good morning, so thank
you so much for having me.
A couple of different things I wanna talk
about this morning.
Most of all, when I think
about the makeup of the room
when you speak and you
have a general audience,
it's so important to find
the thing that most connects
everybody in the room.
And for me
that thing very much is attention,
if you really understand
what everybody here is trying
to accomplish, it's attention.
We're very much in a place
where if you're unable
to get the attention of the end consumer,
of the person you're trying to reach,
you absolutely have no chance
of actually accomplishing
the goal at hand.
If you're an entrepreneur, if
you're a university professor,
if you're in the B2B space,
if you're a content producer,
if you're a startup,
an executive, everybody here
has to focus on actually
getting the attention
of the end consumer
and then starting to create
context for that goal.
The reason I spend so much time
thinking about social media
over the last decade, is
because way back when,
when this came out
and how many people here
by show of hands are over
40 years old?
Raise your hand.
Thank you.
Under 30?
Okay, so for you youngsters in here,
(audience chuckling)
when this came out for all of us over 40,
I think a lot of you can remember that
there was a lot of debate
on how it expensive it was.
Uh how many people here had
a BlackBerry in their life,
raise your hands?
Hold them up high, I want the kids
to look at all these people.
(audience laughing)
Higher.
Keep those lights on if you don't mind,
I like seeing the faces.
You can put them down.
Every person that just raised their hands,
when the iPhone came out
said, "I'm not getting
an iPhone, I can't feel
the buttons on the phone."
(audience laughing)
That was the big debate, the
big debate the reason people
told me that they would not
get this, is because they liked
the fact that they got
used to the BlackBerry
and they could type
quickly without looking.
What I understood was this
was an operating system,
that this was connected to
the single most important
invention, maybe in the
human race, or at least up
to this point, which
is called the Internet.
Everybody in this room
including myself, is grossly
underestimating the impact of the Internet
on the human race.
And so, you know, the Internet
started gaining real traction
on the consumer level in
the mid 90's, late 90's
depending on what market you're in,
but the reality is for me
the thing that I really
want to accomplish today,
is get every person from
that corner to that corner
and back to understand
that it is highly likely, highly likely,
that the breakthrough, or the
advancement, or the growth
that you're looking for
comes at the expense
of you understanding that
you're actually a media company
and not what else you do.
I believe that everybody will
realize over the next decade
that almost everything in our
society is being commoditized
except the ability to communicate.
That when you think about what
you do, the product you sell
and your ability to communicate it
is fundamentally what's left.
The Internet will become the wholesaler,
the distributor, the middle.
There used to be enormous
value in the middle,
the people that had the
middle controlled everything.
The families were entrepreneurs
or media companies
that shot satellites into space,
or owned the printing
press or radio stations,
they had control, they distributed.
Distribution was where the
leverage was because if
they didn't pick you, you
weren't able to see the day
of light, they were
able to keep the value.
Today this is the distribution.
Today
the value chain to
making something happen,
whether that is to become
the President of Mexico,
or to sell sneakers, the
value chain of your ability
to leverage this distribution
is the punch line.
I believe that no different
than taking care of
your physical health to live longer,
or knowing how to balance
your check book is important
to keep your business alive,
that the new requirement
of the next decade is the ability
for you to be a communications executer.
That no longer,
no longer are we in a place
where that can be outsourced
or misunderstood.
Many of us in this
audience as I look around,
grew up in a world where
the media had 100% control
of the narrative outside
of spending a lot of money
in advertising to be able to communicate.
You know, given the way the
world's working I value,
especially cause I was
born in the Soviet Union,
I value journalism and the media
greater than ever not less,
however that does not
take out of the equation
the fact that every single
person here whether through
LinkedIn, a podcast,
Facebook, Twitter, Instagram,
WhatsApp, has the ability to
become their communicator.
And so for me, it's been very fascinating,
it's been fascinating to
watch how many businesses
are getting disrupted, how many
organizations, institutions
are getting disrupted and
yet, I would argue that it
is highly unlikely that
what I just talked about
for the last 10 minutes is something
that is so profound for this room.
I would argue what I just
spoke about for the last
10 minutes, is borderline common sense
or just reaffirmation of something
you absolutely already know.
The important part of this
conversation, this keynote,
is not what I just framed up.
That is not even a debatable aspect.
The question is, if you agree
and understand everything
that I just talked about,
why are you not communicating
five to 55 times a day?
My question in this room
is, I don't think I dropped
any remarkable knowledge
in the last 10 minutes,
my question is, why am I making
at the scale that I'm making
everyday, why are the
people that are advancing
culturally in business, in
every arena, are the ones
who are actually making
content, and why are you
and your organization not?
Why are you still stuck
in a world of politics
and subjectiveness internally
to push out content?
Why are you still in a
world where you value
the production quality as
quality not the message
that it's being delivered in?
Why are you wiling to live
your life as a individual
or an organization, based on
a communications and media
landscape that no longer exists?
(few people clapping)
Thank you Mom.
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
My friends, this is a
super interesting talk,
I'm even feeling it in my own head.
I'm like talking to myself as I'm talking,
I'm like, "This is remarkable,
this is actually remarkable."
What I'm talking about
is uncomfortably basic.
The Internet has changed
the way we communicated
why aren't you using it?
Thank you very much, Mexico, see ya.
Like that's literally,
that's literally the talk.
This is what, how many people
here consume my content,
raise your hands?
I'm just curious, thank you.
(audience cheering)
So, and how many of those
hands have been consuming
for longer than three years?
By show of hands.
Thank you.
(chuckles) Smaller.
(audience laughing)
The people that just raised their hands,
if they're sitting next
to you will tell you
that over the last three years
I've become less tactical
and have started talking
more about parenting,
and patience, and more mindset,
because I am so uncomfortable
with the first 10 minutes
of this talk.
My friends, how do you not
understand that you have
to produce 100 pieces of content a day?
How do you not understand
that everyday that you wake up
whether it for yourself,
or for your business,
or your ambition, or your organization,
how do you not understand
that you should be putting
out 50 to 100 pieces of content a day?
10 tweets, 15 posts on LinkedIn and,
and LinkedIn excuse me.
A podcast,
a vlog,
like what's the conversation here?
Nobody has leverage over you anymore,
this is the distribution, this is it.
This and the eight to
10 websites that work
in your market.
Does Mexico have different
dynamics than the US, of course.
Does WhatsApp have more
equity here than it does
in the US sure.
Is Tik Tok bigger right
now in the US, sure.
But it's still the same
game, I'm agnostic,
I don't care if you wanna
talk about telegraph
or WhatsApp, Facebook,
or Instagram, it's still
the same game.
It is a pipe on top of
the Internet and you need
to figure out how to talk on it.
When I say talk there's only
three things, it's so basic.
The written word,
audio,
and video.
It's been like this for a long time,
you could be in the newspaper
business, in the radio
business, or the television
business and all of it is here
and you don't have to
pay for distribution.
Let me say that one more time.
(audience laughing)
I'm 44
in a week,
(audience laughing)
and even at my young of an
age, I remember a day in age
when I ran business where
I had to pay a lot of money
to the New York Times.
I had to pay a lot of
money to the post office
to send direct mail, I
had to pay a lot of money
to the local radio station
to have a host read my ad.
I had to pay.
I had to pay a lot of money
for the gatekeeper of awareness
to let me have a chance to talk to you.
I don't pay anything now.
Now, I don't pay anything
for the distribution,
I pay for people creating content.
D-Rock where you at?
There you go.
(audience cheering)
D-Rock's not free.
(audience laughing)
He might think it's a good deal, I do too.
I think he'll win in the
end, but none the less,
the shift of economics has changed.
Think about how more
exciting it is for all of us
in this room that our cost
to reach our customer,
whether B2B, whether 80 years
old, whether 16 years old,
whether B2C,
our cost is now
an internal cost
not an external cost.
Not to mention
that
the amount of talent that is being created
at the 13 to 22 year old
level, and currently sits
in the 20 to 30 year old
level, of people that know
how to create,
is remarkable.
There is an extraordinary
amount of 25 year olds
on earth today that would
much rather get paid minimum
legal wage in their society
to video tape and make content
for YouTube and Instagram,
than they would to make double
that salary doing
something they don't love.
That is the mindset of
the millennial user,
that is an incredible relationship.
That is an opportunity both for business
and that individual.
My friends,
there is so many
conversations in our system
that have nothing to do
with the actual realities
of our game.
The actual realities of
our game, life, is that
we have transcended into
a new era where everybody
in this room has to think of
themselves like a journalist,
like a movie producer, like a radio host,
and that is a requirement.
For the last decade that
I've been screaming on stages
all over the world, it has been a luxury.
Let me say this very
carefully, I want everybody
to pay attention, this I
no different than in 1995
to 2003 when I was speaking
in much smaller places
in New Jersey, when I
would say having a website
was a luxury in 1997,
it became a requirement in 2005.
My friends, the time
of you being able to not produce content
on the 10 social networks
or content platforms of our society,
the time of that being a luxury
is going away and we are
going into the decade
of where it is a requirement.
This is very important to me
and I'm desperately trying
to get it through to
everybody because I don't know
what other way to curse
or what other way to make
a content piece, or
what clever thing to do,
what quote to put over a
picture of me on a stage.
I'm running out of different
ways to say the same thing.
And here it is one more time
for the kids in the back.
(audience laughing)
Unless you tomorrow
understand
that whatever your ambition is,
whatever you want to happen
professionally and personally,
unless you understand the requirement
is to produce as much content as possible
you will be out maneuvered
by somebody else.
What I'm seeing that's fascinating
to me is the following,
as many of you know for a
decade, but definitely for
a half a decade, I've been
screaming about the opportunities
of social networks.
Over the last year we're
starting to start to see
the cracks of the biggest
companies in the world
starting to consider to move
their budgets into this world.
Some are pulling out because
they don't like the politics
of Facebook, others are pulling in.
In very basic data, not opinion, the cost
of the Facebook ads have gone up not down.
This is because people
realize it's actually working.
I can stand here today
and tell everybody here
that if they have a...
How many people here
are in the B2C business,
actually selling to end consumers?
Just raise your hands.
For every hand that just went
up, I can tell you right now
in Mexico right this second,
for customers 18 to 45
on the consumer lens, that Instagram
story ads,
so the ads in stories
not in the main feed,
are so uncomfortably under priced
that the two and three
dollar CPM's to reach
a thousand Mexican citizens
in a targeting capability,
is so unfathomable
that if you actually make
25 and 50 pieces of content
for the ad not one, because
you know you're targeting
26 to 32 year old females in Mexico City,
who are interested in soft
drinks or what have you,
that the upside is extraordinary.
I can leave that right now tactically.
I can leave tactically,
that the pre-roll ads on
YouTube in this country,
when you factor in the
search queries on Google,
are some of the best video
ad content in the world.
That there is so much
consumption of YouTube
in this country and so
few taking advantage of
the pre-roll ads that your
ability to build awareness,
not conversion sales,
but awareness brand marketing,
not selling, in pre-roll YouTube form
is unprecedented.
Unprecedented.
I'm just trying to convince
somebody to test it, to do it.
We sit around all day and it's
very important for everybody
in this room to figure this
out, you have to understand
are you a salesman or are you a marketer?
And both are okay, but the
problem for so many people
is they get confused and
think they're doing marketing
when they're actually doing sales.
And it's super important.
How many people here are entrepreneurs?
Raise your hands.
So for me this, which is a
enormous percentage of this room,
this is where this gets very important.
Everything I'm talking about
compounds in importance
for entrepreneurs because,
how many one more time,
and can you put the lights on?
How many people are
entrepreneurs, raise your hands?
Hold them up.
The amount of time, thank
you, the amount time
that the hands that just
went up, that is spent
on trying to figure out how
to get fundraising, is devastating.
We are living through the
golden era of entrepreneurs
who have become incapable of
building practical businesses
without the notion of raising
an enormous amount of capital.
For all the hands that just
went up, I would wish for you
if you had your great
grandparents or grandparents
that actually were entrepreneurs
too, for you to have
a conversation with them
about how you're thinking
about executing your
business versus how they did.
We are living in a world
where so many people now
spend all their time thinking
about how, and especially
when you're not in America
and even in America,
when you're not in
Silicon Valley, there are
uncomfortable amounts of
hours in this room of people
in meetings crying about
the fact that it's hard
to raise capital.
It should be hard to raise capital.
This notion of entitlement
that because you have
a fucking idea, that you
deserve money for it to do it,
is laughable.
It is a disease in America,
it is a disease in Asia,
it is a disease in Latin
America, the notion that you have
to raise capital to start.
I started VaynerMedia
by starting the company
in a conference room of another
company so I didn't have
to pay rent and I worked for a
couple weeks to find somebody
to pay me for a project,
and I took that money
and that's how I hired our first employee.
You can build a business
without raising capital.
(audience member cheering)
Thanks, cause it's real.
(audience clapping)
My friends, we're living
through the greatest era
of fake entrepreneurship right now.
(audience laughing)
It's gotten so cool that
everybody wants to be one
and it scares me.
Listen, I was one, I'm
benefiting from the popularity
of entrepreneurship.
That doesn't mean that I
don't wanna talk about all
the perils when you try
to be an entrepreneur
when you're not.
I wanna remind this room
that the 17th employee
at Facebook made a lot
more money than 99.99999%
of entrepreneurs.
Entrepreneurship on a pedestal
is a very dangerous game,
it's extremely lonely,
it's extremely difficult,
and the reality is, to
be a true entrepreneur
that's able to navigate
successfully you have to be
in a position where you
have a great relationship
with the judgment.
People struggle with
judgment, especially from
their friends and family.
Judgment is the poison of our
society and it is accelerated
where you have nowhere to hide.
How many people here are
employees, you work somewhere,
raise your hand?
Raise 'em, don't worry raise 'em high.
(audience laughing)
For everybody who just raised their hand,
I think being in an employee is phenomenal
and I'll tell you why.
The best part of being an
employee is you always have
somebody else to blame.
(audience laughing)
One of the reasons I know
that we're living through
the greatest era of entrepreneurship
is because I get hundreds
and thousands of DM's
and messages, and I have
meetings with entrepreneurs
everyday, and I am
fascinated with their ability
to spend the majority of our
time together complaining
or
painting a picture of other people within
their organization being at
fault for their lack of success.
Entrepreneurs one more time,
I apologize, hands in the air.
Let me give you my best
tidbit before I leave,
100% of the problems with your company
is 100% your fault.
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
When I tell you that
there are 500 problems
at VaynerMedia that I
can think of right now,
I can do that right now,
they're all my fault,
because the people that are
running those situations
I hired them.
They may suck,
(audience laughing)
but it's my responsibility to
fire them and replace them.
I'm also the one that hired
them or I hired the person
that hired them.
If you raised your hand
and you're an entrepreneur
I promise you the quickest
way to happiness and success
is 100% blind accountability.
It's not fun.
You know earlier I was
with a group of people
and we got into a
conversation around parenting
and technology, everybody
wants to blame Facebook,
and Instagram, and
cellphones, because they don't
want to be accountable for the
fact that they have created
children with no self esteem
and are 100% entitled.
It's a lot more fun to blame
something else than it is
to blame yourselves.
It's a lot more fun for you
to sit around a dinner table
and blame Mexico's
government for your lack
of success not you.
My friends, life is very basic
there's always something.
You know, as I'm sure you
know there's a lot of tension
politically within the US,
and there's a lot of people
complaining, and worried, and upset.
And there's plenty to fix,
we have many shortcomings,
but let me promise you this,
in the globe the eight billion
of us, 7.7 billion of us,
there's never been a
better time to be alive.
- [Female In Audience] Marry my startup.
- Marry your startup?
- [Female In Audience] Yeah.
- Well I need to know what it is.
(audience laughing)
Well you send me an
email and I'll read it.
You got it.
(audience cheering)
So,
(audience clapping)
before that lovely lady
just interrupted my flow,
(audience laughing)
which leads to almost guaranteed no shot
of marrying her startup,
(audience laughing)
the point I'm trying
to make is very simple.
We are not living through
the world war era,
we are not living
through the black plague.
People are like, "Gary, I
can't raise for my startup."
I'm like, "You know
what's worse than that?
The Holocaust."
(audience laughing)
You know, as somebody who
loves history, especially
the last 100 years in the
world, there is so much that
has happened in this great
country in the last 100 years
that has been far more
difficult climates to execute
your entrepreneurial dream,
than the one that you're sitting
in right now fluffy in a
conference listening to me talk.
My friends, we need to eliminate excuses.
Excuses are quite popular.
Excuses are fun and easy.
Excuses come when actual macro-prosperity
is actually happening.
And so I really spend a lot more time now
thinking about perspective,
than I do around a lot of
other things that are tactical.
Tactically I can sit here, and
I'm gonna actually sit here
cause I'm in the mood right
now, I'm getting a little
serious here, I can sit here
tactically and say to you,
"Listen, my entire career
has been built on the fact
that I'm very good at
understanding where organic reach
to the end consumer."
I changed my mind, "Where
organic reach to the end consumer
is very under priced."
Let me explain, I was smart
enough, intuitive enough,
gifted with the ability to
understand people enough,
whatever you wanna call
it to understand in 1995
that the Internet was not a fad
and that people would use it.
And so instead of opening
a second liquor store
for my family business,
I launched a website,
that was considered crazy.
That worked.
I also understood in 1997
that people would read email.
How many people here had email
in 1999, raise your hands?
Stand up, stand up, stand
up if you had email in 1999.
Please don't be lazy I just
want the room to see this.
Okay, first let's clap it
up for these dinosaurs.
(audience clapping and cheering)
I'm one.
Stay please, please, I
want people to see this.
Put the lights on.
Please stand if you had
email, if you're being lazy
please stand if you had email in 1999,
I want to see the numbers.
Thank you.
By the people standing by a show of hands
or shake your head, cause I
want everybody to see this,
do you remember in 1999
when we would get an email,
do you remember that we
read every fucking word
of every email?
Recall?
(Audience chattering)
That, you can sit thank you, that,
that my friends who have been sitting,
that's what I was good at.
I understood in 1999
that people had email,
that it was free to send an
email, and that they read it.
And that is why I started
an email newsletter
instead of a paper newsletter,
which I wish you understood
in 1999 was crazy.
In 1999 starting an email
newsletter instead of a printed
newsletter would be like
somebody here who's in financial
services starting a Tik
Tok account tomorrow.
(audience laughing)
It made no sense to people.
I also knew that in 2001
or 2, I don't recall,
that Google ad words, and
Google search organic,
was under priced.
That I thought Google would defeat Yahoo,
that people would search and
if you typed in Cabernet,
or Bordeaux, that it was
good for my store to show up.
I had no money, my Dad
had a local liquor store
that was doing three million
dollars a year almost four,
on 10% gross profit.
$400,000 gross before expenses
of employees, and water,
and rent, no money.
My first year in marketing
budget was less than $30,000.
And really it was zero, but I
had to find it somewhere else.
My career has been predicated
on under priced attention,
that's why I was first on
YouTube, that's why I was earliest
on Twitter and Facebook.
Finally by the time I was 32,
33 I got smart and started
investing in the companies
not just using it,
but I can sit here today
cause I still have this talent
and I'm still in the dirt.
The reason I run VaynerMedia,
is I want to be in the dirt.
When you're in the dirt
you know what's going on.
When you're in the clouds,
when you're in an ivory tower,
you do not.
I stay in the dirt, which
allows me on this morning
on November 7th, 2019, with
all the success and opportunity
I have, I can deliver to
this room the tactical advice
that what built me, email,
website, Google search, YouTube,
Facebook, is 100% happening right now
on LinkedIn and Tik Tok, 100%.
You could have no profile on
either one of those accounts,
go write an article on
LinkedIn, four sentences
five sentences that brings
value not as a commercial
for your business, and by
the time you wake up the next
morning 30, 90, 400 people
that have never heard of you
have now heard of you and
half of them, 80% of them,
agree with you and one
of them or two of them
is intrigued by you.
I just don't understand,
specially for all the hands
that went up early, when
I say this everyday,
how many of them still don't make content.
This leads to insecurity,
this leads into this stuff.
When people say, "Gary, I
want more tactics from you."
I'm like, "I'm very easy with
tactics, just watch everything
I'm doing and do that too."
(audience laughing)
I mean it.
I'm not throwing around
my cell number in America
for text numbers for my health
or cause I think it's funny,
I'm doing it because I believe
that we're in the early
stages of social medias macro decline
and that I want the first
party data of having
my end users phone number so
I can talk to them directly
because I don't like that I
have seven million followers
on Instagram, but when I
hit post a small fraction
of those seven million people see it.
Now, I'm not a crybaby like
everybody else that's mad
that the organic reach is
down, cause I'm very aware
that it is free.
Watching, remember
Facebook a couple years ago
when you would post on
your page and the numbers
went down and everybody was
crying and mad at Zuck's?
I kept trying to remind
everybody, I'm like, "It's free."
(audience laughing)
Instagram does not charge you,
YouTube does not charge you
to go on the platform and distribution.
Television, print, radio,
outdoor billboards charge you.
This is free, for distribution.
This will be the next decade
of communication warfare,
we will separate as
organizations and as people,
as the people that are the
have's versus the have not's.
Many of you over the next
decade will fire or restructure
your businesses to bring in
journalists, videographers,
designers, cartoonists,
animators, you will start
slowly but surely understanding
how true what I'm saying is.
This is going to be a
communication warfare.
You will also bring in
math oriented individuals
that understand how to navigate organic
and paid distribution in
whatever the Facebook's,
and LinkedIn's, and Tik Tok's
are of a decade of today.
Whether they're all there
or none of them are there,
I could care less.
In a weird way I almost prefer
that tomorrow every social
network and content platform
disappeared off the face
of the earth, because then
everybody would be stunned
and where do you go and my
greatest skill is finding
where the attention is, and I believe
that I could gather the most.
Whether that is going back to
print, going back to radio,
I could care less.
Tactical, I believe that 90% of this room
should start a podcast.
I believe that 90% of this
room should start a podcast.
I believe that over the
next decade and start,
and even now,
that the rise of audio
consumption has exploded.
By show of hands, sorry
to the lighting people,
by show of hands how many
people here now listen
to at least one podcast
at least once a week?
Raise your hands.
Raise it high, people in the
front look at how staggering
this number is.
Put 'em down.
Of the people that just
raised their hand, how many
of you listened to a
podcast at least once a week
five years ago?
Raise your hand.
Look around.
What I just showed you by
a show of hands, thank you.
What I just showed you by a show of hands,
is what I do for a living.
I day trade
attention.
When I wrote "Crushing
It", this book up here,
which is my last book in the yellow,
if you can see it, up
there I have the logos
of the platforms that I talked about.
Instagram, Snapchat,
Facebook, Twitter, podcasting,
YouTube, this was my book
of the contemporary places
to execute what I just talked about.
This is 18 months old.
Not LinkedIn nor Tik Tok
show up on that book.
Yet, it has been the far
majority of what I've talked
to you about this morning.
In 18 months I come back here,
or come out with another book,
or give another keynote, I
may not even utter the words
LinkedIn or Tik Tok.
The skillset that is required
going forward for any business
in a communications warfare,
is the ability to understand
where the attention is and be able
to produce content for it.
The single biggest reason
most of you will not be able
to go back home and execute
on the model that I just told
you about, the single reason,
is because
of judgment of the content itself.
Many of you do not go on
video because you're insecure
of the way you look on video.
That's okay with me, that's human nature.
What is not acceptable for me
is for you not to challenge
yourself to figure out
what kind of communicator
you actually are.
Are you capable of writing,
are you capable of taking
your phone hitting the
memos and just talking
for six minutes and posting that?
Are you capable of video?
I'm an intuitive communicator operator,
had I been a hardcore quant
analytical operator, I
would be sitting here
this morning showing you slides,
showing you incredible
math and charts completely
affirming what I'm talking about.
When you just look at the sheer
consumption that we as human
beings now take into
content because of this,
you used to not be able to
watch television when you
were on the bus, you had
to get home and watch it.
My friends, what is happened in our lives
is a very big deal.
When we are long gone and
it is 500 years from now,
I promise you, many will
look back to this 50 years
as a turning point in the human race.
The Internet, the inevitability
of the block chain,
and many other technologies,
is a very substantial deal.
It is now executing and
affecting your business.
Please, please, please,
please hear me loud and clear
this morning and understanding
that this is very basic,
this is no different than
if I was giving a keynote
this morning about health.
If I was talking about physical
health I would be talking
about eating better and working out.
You wanna get into better shape,
I have the secret everyone,
(audience laughing)
stop eating shit,
and workout every morning.
Yet, an incredible amount
of people here continue
to look for some magic formula
of apple juice vinegar,
(audience laughing)
of some fucking waist thing
that you wear 24 hours a day
that fucking shrinks your shit.
(audience laughing)
Of plastic surgery, of doctors,
of some miraculous shortcut
to not put in the work.
That is what I'm speaking
about today in the form
of entrepreneurship and business.
It is become unbelievably
clear, very clear,
there is your product, your
product the thing you sell,
yourself, your time, your
product and then nothing
anymore in the middle which
used to be the whole game.
Stores,
networks,
wholesalers, media companies, the middle,
that used to be the game,
this is not the game.
Your product
and your ability to tell me about it,
the end.
And until you become
religious about those two,
you will become vulnerable.
The first about your
product, that's on you,
I don't how good of a
lawyer you are, I don't know
how good of a mason you
are, I don't know how good
of a flower shop,
steel manufacturer,
educator,
I don't know, you've
gotta work on your craft.
But I promise you this,
this part right here,
this parts very interesting
to me I'll tell you why.
If I could have you better
at one of those two things,
I would have you better at this,
because the quality of something
is subjective,
the ability to communicate
and make one believe
of its quality, is the way it
gets played out and results.
Until everybody takes a
big step back and realizes
that communication
on cell phones today,
and more importantly and this is why,
let me get to the punchline,
let me tell you why
I only care
about you building brand.
In the next decade we
will see the emergence
of a technology that I think
is potentially unbelievably
disruptive and that is
voice devices in our homes
that are AI assisted.
Google Home, Apple Pod,
Amazon Alexa,
many other companies that are gonna pop up
in other parts of the world
that are gonna compete,
I believe that there is a naivety
and a misunderstanding of
how potentially powerful
these devices are.
Everything that is worked
for me over the last 20 years
has been grounded in my unbelievable
belief that you
chose convenience and speed almost over
anything else in the world.
That while mainstream media
continues to try to tell us
that we care about privacy,
I watch you everyday
give up privacy for convenience.
If I needed to go find a
wonderful place to eat right now,
15 years ago with none of your help,
I would have to go look
at a print product,
a yellow pages like product,
a magazine that says best
restaurants in Monterrey, it
would take me a long time.
Today I can choose this and
within three to four minutes
be in the game.
In a half a decade to a
decade I can say, "Alexa,
what's the best restaurant in Monterrey?"
And get the answer like this. (snapping)
I can get my babysitter, I
can book my calendar invite,
I can make every decision with
an AI assisted voice device.
If you are in the food business
and you're in the pizza
business, and you're the best
at Google and you show up
first, and you're posting
remarkable photo's on Instagram
about your pizza and all those things,
that's very very nice.
However, unless you are
capable of building a brand
that comes out of my mouth,
in a decade when I say,
"Google, send me a pizza."
You're in deep trouble,
because now Google becomes the toll booth.
Google decides what pizza
I'm getting, either A,
the pizza company that Google owns,
(audience laughing)
or B, the pizza company
that spends the most money
for the referral that
they won't even be able
to afford based on their profit margin.
It will not be me typing
in pizza and choosing,
because you bought ads or
you have the best copy.
Brand in a voice world
is the only thing left.
If you have not started
the process of building
your personal brand or the
brand of your organization,
you are going to be
uncomfortably vulnerable
in the next decade or two's advancements.
I wanna remind this
room as a parting shot,
that everything we talk about
today from smart phones,
to social networks, to
Netflix, to everything,
Ubers and on and on and on,
everything we talk about
did not exist 15 years ago.
Did not exist.
If you think a lot has
happened since then to now,
wait til you see what happens
over the next 15 years
because the stack of technologies in place
for far quicker advancement.
Unless you are storytelling
and producing content
that is either educational
or entertaining,
either bringing people the
ability to escape their normal
life, which is why they
will consume it, or educate
and be a utility, you
will be squeezed out.
Today,
today needs to be the day
that you stop thinking
about it and debating it,
today must become the day
that you are in the
singular business of ideas
of what you want to say
and actually making it.
My friends, if you are not
putting out 10, 20, 30, 70
pieces of content a day,
you have started the process
to being completely irrelevant.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)